1680 paris had 450 000 inhabitants the east the bastille louvre palace just to the west the open
countryside king ruled alone absolute monarch france was spreading her riches throughout the
world her army was victorious the treaty of nijmegen made louis 14th europe's strongest ruler the sun
king had indeed reached his zenith master master is dying of wounds you must hurry he suffered
grievous wounds during a duel something to try and save my good master i'll look into it save him
Oh, you mustn't just let him die, my good man.
There must surely be something, a cure.
Oh, my good master.
Oh, I beg of you, do something.
Oh, it's not that bad.
Oh, if only your words could come true.
God bless you.
Thanks.
Now step it up.
He may die at any moment.
Better get dressed and go fetch the boy.
Who knows?
I may need you both.
I'm going.
Don't hurry it up.
They're going to let him die.
Next, please.
He's all right.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Hold on, look at the chart.
Saturn, kidneys, that's it.
Ha ha, service is well rendered.
1680, renovation work at the Palace of Versailles was nearly completed.
King had never forgotten how inadequate he felt when 20 years before,
he had been received in gaudy splendor by his finance minister, Fouquet.
From then on, he had promised himself a more worthy dwelling.
A little more to the left.
No, a bit more to the right.
A little further, too far.
No, to the right.
No, there, no, no, there, that's fine.
In 1661, Versailles had been nothing more than a hunting lodge, a favorite hideaway of Louis XIV.
Six years later, much work had already been done, and then Laveau decided to enclose the original building.
It will be a marvel, majesty, a true gem. The world will envy you.
The painter Le Brun took thorough charge of decorations.
Hold on, I'm mousy, and he's more color. Wait a minute, I prefer blue, a lot of blue, red.
He designed the gardens, and then Hardouin Mansart was called in to replace Laveau.
For the time being, the Sun King was still living in the Louvre,
close to his subjects, whom he didn't trust.
Come on! Faster! We'll never get there in time to save my poor master!
Hurry up a bit! We're here! Finally!
So you must admit it's incredible.
Go on! Go on!
Stop on it! Please hurry!
Well, then I said, "Pardon me, dear Marquis."
Watch out, will you? Come on!
I'm sorry! I'm sorry! Come on!
Back of you!
I just don't know what to do. Nothing has worked. We've tried everything.
And what treatments have been administered?
He's been bled most of the time.
Bleeding time.
Huh?
Insist.
And the patient's diet, ma'am?
He hardly eats.
What's this?
Oh, it's true, he barely touches, I assure you, he hardly eats.
Yes, yes, I see, I see.
Fine, well, since we're all of one accord, we'll have to change all that.
And we'll try this.
He said bleeding time.
No.
Huh?
Uh, uh, enough.
Hey, friends, I need your help right away.
Naughty boy to the closet oh, no, mommy mommy and keep still in there this
A bit of rest. You'll be as good as new
Now it is a bit much you realize course you were in the wrong the right-of-way
I mean really I did have the right-of-way
And you are fine fine fine now we'll have to report it
Yeah, we're gonna see we're gonna report this now
Thank you
You keep him down on the farm eh, Bumpkin
First in Grand Central Station
Did you matter?
Yes
Shut up!
Today's youth get ahead!
Ha ha ha ha!
It's silly!
I've been expert hands, I've pulled teeth with absolutely no pain guarantee!
Come on all!
You see my pain?
Yeah, Magic Potion will bring you back your long-lost youth!
Gimme some, you're trying!
We're both in costume!
Crack!
I'm nothing!
Take that!
Hang on!
Can't you see we're in a rush?
He's got all the time in the world!
Take your time, pal!
Yeah, we're working!
One moment, one moment, mister, I've just parked here for three minutes.
Oh, hey, I'm kind of nuts.
He won't get away with this, I've got connections.
Oh, oh.
1682 was moving.
The Louvre to Versailles just recently finished.
The court, the ministers, the thousand clerks and civil servants making up the king's entourage
were used to following his majesty from castle to castle across the country.
Jazz from Vincent to Fontainebleau or from Saint-Germain to Chambord.
After all, a move was necessary from time to time, if only to clean up all the mess.
Come on, I have to write it down for you, huh?
Hurry, hurry, hurry, faster, faster, or he'll write it all down for us.
Come on there, get going.
Oh, I'm wearing my nerves out.
All right, well, step it up. Come on, come on, come on.
Come on, come on, come on.
What a mess, he forever.
Guy would be different.
Louis remembered the humiliations of the Fron revolts and their threat to his power.
So it was political necessity that made him require all his courtiers to live at Versailles, and 3000 did so.
currying favor with his majesty became their full-time occupation things will be humming soon
these days he'll blow up the whole house master your noble patient summons you to versailles no
no i'm not quite i just say well it's true this money could help my poor clients well right
just this once we'll take a look no no no thanks anyway but like ancient athens and rome france
was looked up to for her knowledge of the art of living glorification of the king was the foremost
concern of every artist at court. French classicism did bring together a
number of brilliant minds. Descartes, Pascal, Molière, followed by La Fontaine, Boileau,
La Brouillère, Madame de Savigny, Bossuet and Racine. Lully was in charge of music.
You shoot, it's excellent. Scorpions and white bullfrogs powdered and mashed with
you'll be a well man. Come on. No, no, it's you, it's you.
huh not you again take that off or to me this will do you a world of good
there well back your kidneys some wood louse powder dried goat's blood and oil of scorpion
or gout let's see what we've got you'll be needing woman's milk and some nice tepid cow
woman's milk and warm cow dog and make it snappier the sun was louis 14 symbol and with it went the
myth of the sun god the olympic deities became louis 14th triumphal theme at versailles yes louis
the conqueror 14th reigning on mount olympus a king who believed he was divine helped along by
his courtier's ample praise he lived in complete isolation from the outside world in 1683 sobieski
king of poland france's ally defeated the turks at vienne the turks also french allies had helped
offset the strength of the austrian emperor now regained his power in that same year queen marie
Therese died, as well as Colbert, only to be replaced by the Marquise de Maintenon and Louvois.
The Marquise was not interested in the rollicking life of the court.
Her passions were the church and politics.
And so, to everyone's surprise, Louis became a religious fanatic.
He revoked the Edict of Nantes in 1685.
Persecuted once again, the Huguenots fled abroad by the thousands.
The bravest fled, and the prosperous.
And a chorus of praise went to the king for this pious act,
which robbed France of much dignity and strength, and strengthened her enemies.
That was the price of intolerance.
Louis XIV declared,
The tranquility of my subjects lies only in obedience.
It's always preferable for the people to be passive,
than to control even the faulty government of kings,
who answer only to God.
Now, rise and shine.
Am I to understand that you don't want breakfast?
I think, aren't ya?
Mm-mm-mm-mm-mm.
There you go.
Get us five.
Ha-ha-ha-ha.
Here's your paper.
*laughs*
Thanks pal.
It's sign.
Don't wait.
You're stubborn as mules.
Now watch!
Hey me, deadheads!
King's blundering brought William of Orange, his chief rival, to power.
In no time, all Europe united against Louis.
Then a series of brutal winters.
The people were in a wretched state.
King's troops, exhausted, coaxed what little they could out of the barren soil.
In a few months, 10% of the population had died.
After a brief interlude of peace at the end of the century,
The Spanish succession triggered war once again.
The unpopular king, isolated in his palace, pursued his life of splendor.
For him, he would die of natural causes, and not at the people's hand.
In 1711, England, who feared the strength of a combined Austria and Spain, left the anti-French coalition.
Get them all.
And in 1712, at Denay, Marshall Villar won an unhoped-for victory.
France saved face, but at dreadful cost.
This should help.
September 1st, 1715, after 72 years of rule, 54 of them as absolute monarch, Louis XIV was no more.
His countrymen breathed a sigh of relief, a far cry from their former adoration for their king as a youth.
Louis had stood firm by France throughout all her difficult times,
but his greed and outsized need for glory had made him blind to reality and his people's misery.
England, who by artful maneuvering had prevented Spain from joining with either Austria or France,
had wangled the right to explore and settle Canada, and much of America.
French classicism lingered on.
All of Europe began to copy French styles.
Austria's Schönbrunn, Sweden's Drattningholm, Spain's Madrid and La Grana,
Russia's Peterhof and Koskovo, Italy's Cassette, England's Hampton Court,
Russia's Potsdam, and in all countries the nobility spoke and even thought in French.
As for absolute power, it would soon be swept aside, and the age of reason would take over.
An age foreseen by Racine, Pascal, Descartes, and by other great minds of the time.
Spinoza, Leibniz, and Newton.